[Music]
this is my world
I would pay good money the price of a
movie ticket even to see it being
animated kids movie that didn't start
with narration like is this now a
requirement has it always been a
requirement I don't remember Mickey
coming on in the opening scenes of
Steamboat Willie can explicitly
introducing his universe this is me I
think it's a parent I need to rethink my
life a little bit at that elevation and
those temperatures I imagine all you
have is ice so where did you get those
frozen flowers butterflies and that
giant pile of fruit there's no way
you're finding all that in this closed
ecosystem see we have these laws that
are written in stone the stones I'm here
to protect us common law interpreted and
enforced by the stone keeper oh so he's
pretty much Morgan Freeman and wanted
breeding that King loom of fate book
like how the world was created when we
all fell from the butt of the great sky
yeah good to know right off the bat that
this movie will be dealing with religion
and Dogma a nuanced and meaningful way
my favorite stone of all is the one that
says the gong must be rung to wake the
great glowing snail man I don't care who
came up with this story but I sure do
wish I knew that persons drug dealer
let's see small foot animal crackers the
Lorax little spirit Hercules Space Jam
few things in post-production yep I
think we've got plenty of material to
say Danny DeVito voices an adorable
character and an animated movie cliche I
guess you could say I'm learning the
ropes and the wheel and the crank damn
sounds like the puberty process for
Christian Grey because there's literally
no other way to ring a gong
sarcastically meta referencing the
stupidity of your plot device does not
in any way relieve you of the
responsibility of said stupidity look at
everybody
this is a musical man I know Channing
Tatum doesn't have a bad voice but I'm
not looking forward to listening to
anyone other than zendaya in this cast
trying to carry off an entire song if
I'd known this was gonna be a
presentation of the abominable Shonen I
wouldn't have shown up for work today
also this song about the perfect village
mega lives in is essentially the polar
opposite of the song Belle sings at the
beginning of Beauty and the Beast and
because it's even worse by comparison to
that classic it's earning another sin
great now the movies ripping off
mallanna's how far I'll go but that's
none of the rebellious heart of that
movie so this sucker earns another sip
you want another one movie say the word
just say the word stead of going to
prison you'll come here don't they
believe ringing the gong is the only way
for the Sun to come up can practice gong
would potentially shatter the space-time
continuum right so you join a long line
of family greats
Jesus movie cares as much about
offending victims of chronic head trauma
as the NFL Commissioner and your mom
wish she was here to teach you yeah but
I thought dorable was the one that
descended down the vaunted line of gong
ringers and this is specifically his job
why she immortalized and what could she
have talked Amiga and why is she even
dead what purpose does that serve in all
distort Mego survives I can't be too
sure but from here it looks like Steve
Trevor's back on his boat again the
physics of this plane insane fails
mainly in my brain Wow we're just mowing
down the cliches before the 10-minute
mark a movie let's check the main
character has a pratfall that's supposed
to be hilarious because it's in super
slow motion one off the list
premature eject Alicia no I know Mego
has gotten you all very anxious with his
little story man this is soaking
dismissive that it should immediately be
obvious to at least some of the
villagers that stone keeper is lying
this is like Elaine from Seinfeld asking
and preto what did the doorman say well
the doorman certainly has a wild
imagination doesn't it telephone no how
do you mail look I'm all for a hilarious
sign gags but what does this even mean
why does it say callback at the bottom
why would you need to misspell telephone
yeah what about seeing a Yeti is a
pretty crazy occurrence might even be so
scary that it's the fourth thing you
mentioned to the stranger after you've
told him you were gonna fire a plane
crash then we're yanked off the side of
a fucking mountain by your parachute and
you're probably in need of immediate
medical care I get that he's probably in
a bit of shock and all but did he really
just trek all the way from wherever he
landed without even taking the parachute
off you wonder no one believes you we
believe you you know these believer
assholes aren't exactly shy about their
beliefs they were actively proselytizing
to the kids earlier about the existence
of small foot so why haven't they even
thrown out of the village like Miko
I said this but he's a bit parent cold
the texture rocks like they can hear her
I've been told I'm pesky everyone in
that village had a role and was working
to make the town run perfectly so what
role did the SES members play look I
love my father but he isn't exactly what
you would call open to new ideas staying
it frozen farling that is not how air
quotes work they aren't a way of
emphasizing something they're a way to
say something means something different
than it does on the surface it's called
ironic sarcasm here's an example this
movie's gonna earn at least 10 awards
for this moment alone because when I
said Awards it really meant since got it
now we have searched the entire mountain
for years trying to find one years
between the four of them oh then I found
one even by accident there's a
village-like with an easy walking
distance and there must be hikers around
if there are artifacts also how did they
even get out without anyone noticing
them I thought this was a closed society
or everyone had to be present and
accounted for at all times
shouldn't be that hard of a narrative to
follow then there's this a scroll of
invisible wisdom horror movie but what
the hell I only have four human
artifacts but one of them is a cheap
attempt at toilet humor and how they did
you even get this what mountain a hiker
would ever leave an entire roll of what
looks like very comfortable toilet paper
behind
just imagine the VZ stuff they put on
here would you crap it you asked me we
got jokes y'all just about tearing down
old ideas it's about finding new ones
you know what come with me damn that
escalated quickly
if I were Mego I'd be a little worried
about what Michi means by new ideas
let's talk about perspectives y'all meet
this fully crystallized snowflake on his
finger is taking up just a little less
space as the human boot we saw earlier
meaning the snowflake is roughly the
size of a human fuck
[Music]
jeez lady this isn't the running to be
too preachy a song of all fucking times
[Music]
me go taking her to pleasure town okay
oh go what why did those hallucinogens
michi clearly just used seriously change
Miko's mind that fast
I guess LSD is a hell of a drug we've
already firmly established Looney Tunes
physics in this movie but come on are we
really going full Wiley coyote here you
never go full Wiley coyote this
surprisingly goes on for some time
okay I made a joke about me go surviving
the gone launcher mishaps but this is
full-on Yeti crap right here it's not
like Mego fell off a steep ledge or
something it was all the way down a
goddamn mount don't tell me that
anything else in this movie is supposed
to matter also mountains kind of
mountain shaped how did he fall straight
down for so long without hitting any
sort of slope will be is betting hard
that the audience is all in on the
screaming goat mean I actually don't
mind so much but I bet some kids were
shocked to learn that this movie takes a
hard turn into 127 hours territory that
man has altitude sickness are you still
having this conversation since we left
them we've been through the finding of
the secret skeptic society a neverending
story about the nothing an entire
zendaya song about what makes a
wonderful life coming up with a rope
plan the failure of the rope plan and
the non-stop mountain pratfall I'm not
saying it couldn't be the same day but
if it is there is no way this argument
about the pilot hasn't found some
resolution by now we post the video my
ratings skyrocket viral videos picked up
a suit in town this afternoon and it's a
cracker that's racist also how
convenient you picked up that suit long
before you bumped into the pilot that
mentioned seeing a Yeti it's almost like
the writers knew it would happen I will
take that money and give it to charity
that's how much integrity I will have
seriously James Corden and Kevin Hart
sure are duking it out for the most
annoying voice acting competition it's
at this point that Percy's singing under
pressure and I have to ask how dare you
movie queen you think you can just use
the amazing and timeless music of Queen
to hide the fact that there is barely
any substance to the troit shallowness
you're putting on the screen kind of may
win Golden Globes we won't stand for it
around here
holy did Gordon's character
single-handedly turn this into a Moche
movie - because I did not consent to
that okay I'm not gonna lie as much as
I've given it I was right on the verge
of mildly enjoying this derivative but
she removed but once Percy showed up I'm
having as much fun as watching Justin
Bieber featured on carpool karaoke
from what we've heard
the Yeti roars are super loud to humans
but no one else in the bar can hear any
of this
Himalayan boos must be some good shirt
but isn't the bigger story here that
there's something under the clouds I
know that small foot is an important
discovery that's inconsistent with the
stones but the fact that there's a
foundation of this mountain contradicts
everything the society is based on I
consider doing a bonus round for all the
times Chatham tanning screams in this
movie but honestly I don't have the
energy just trust me that it's a flop
and for that I'll add 20 cents wait when
did the yetis discover Fong there was
none of that the village right how would
he even know what wood is considering
his entire society is covered in
permafrost Comcast out in the pole
another animated movie in which humans
can't understand animals but all the
king animals no matter what species can
understand each other except I guess for
the goats who just screamed because
they're dumb don't be stupid pussy do
don't go back to help the big ferocious
Yeti chicken cordon true here would be
excellent at cinema since wait those are
stars right so where are the clowns
you know the omnipresent manufactured
steamed clowns that extend well past
this mountain and have kept the belief
system of the yetis in place for
centuries
migos never been down here before how
does he know this way up and how much
further it will be before they arrive at
the top oh just a reminder that this
little guy had a tooth finally knocked
out of his head earlier that he won't
even mention until some mid-credits
scene days from now you know as one does
not only has the right stuff parity been
done a million times before and a
million times better it's even been done
by monsters before in monsters a movie
is achieved maximum derivative honestly
I have just as many questions as you did
me too like how does Percy's phone have
any power luck considering he's been
videoing this entire escapade and early
yesterday evening it was already only at
two bars a battery light go down YouTube
comments sections is going on right now
did they just invent the power of flight
during the first verse of this song do
you see what you've started I guess
we're just don't keep her even go during
this montage we couldn't at least try to
keep the harmful creative fervor down a
bit and miss the calm but the sky snail
it came up anyway yeah but there's no
way this hasn't happened before
especially considering the time the Sun
rises would be different throughout the
year and they have no way of timing the
gong perfectly but hey at least we get
to experience dad's extremely crucial be
plot that's exactly the same as the
sun's a plot
I've been banging my head on that thing
to wake up a gas ball that's usually
what wakes me up
movie managed to cram durables entire
existential crisis in between a poop and
a fart joke think it's about time I give
you some answers it's common knowledge
that's like we used to live down there
but there were axes we could not forgive
down jeez which way should I go here the
glut of syllables in that last line the
fact that common just rhymed down there
with down there hmm
I think the rap splaining is the most
offensive part so here goes discount
Hamilton look we know yetis aren't
completely stupid but the village is
still super primitive I mean they
trouble by sticking their hands to a
goddamn ice block so who built this
incredibly sophisticated system of
chamber transportation and if the stone
keepers the only one that uses it why is
it this big so none of those stones are
true they're all lost goodbyes this
movie is M night Shyamalan the village
the village can you believe someone who
wants to fucking village and said hey
that concept would kill as a kids movie
for tonight's performance the part of
stone keeper will be played by Sarah
Huckabee Sanders he wants to take my
home away because of something called a
variable interest rate I mean anyone
could have been the small foot and this
movie would have been at least 90% more
interesting how about Brenda I couldn't
she have been discovered by Amiga candy
crush humor was understandable six years
ago when wreck-it Ralph did it and
Beyond played out by the time emoji
movie did it so I'm not even sure what
to call it now desperate pathetic
desperate etic let's go with that
it's not as more fun yeah I was wrong I
got confused and ego is the easiest
mother in the world to convince to do
something parently just sing him a song
and he'll capitulate to whatever you
want these are lies amigo we saw you go
below the clouds you know for voice
talent LeBron James sure is an excellent
basketball player We Need to Talk I
think you said enough an underrated
quality possessed by the stone keeper is
the ability to suddenly cause a
protagonist fight before the climax of
the movie cliche I was pretty happy when
I didn't know about the small fun hey me
too but then Chris put it on the
schedule and I was like hey what the
hell's that and now we're in the same
boat me go I feel like such a jerk you
know they've been talking for a good
while since doraville woke up and every
other time we've seen the gone wrong
they've gone right out to do the
slingshot thing so what's taking the Sun
so long to come up does it have a sense
of dramatic timing one of
well it's really been a systematic
subterfuge that's been in place for
hundreds of years man has involved who
knows how many previous elders that held
this knowledge but sure man make it all
about you you thought I was kidding when
I mentioned how much screaming there
wasn't this movie didn't you didn't you
okay
movie that's time for this what I know
all right how did she get all the way to
Kathmandu without anyone seeing you
assholes the director said let's draw
your character with an apple when you
react to the Eddie will make you look
like even more of an asshole than those
muttonchops
hey you get the hell out of here with
that banana crap and what the hell kind
of exotic coach is this lady drinking
sorry I got off track so you're an
asshole and super convenient considering
there was no traffic at all going
through these streets when michi was
wandering around for several minutes I
think come on man there is no way this
city is this close to the yack jack or
we would have seen it before now it's
like suddenly finding out Gotham City is
just across the bay from metropolis yes
that's definitely the first thing I do
in this incredibly well-lit city center
when confronted with a large mammal I
know nothing about me G we're here it's
okay even though there was an entire
police force tracking Michi it's
amazingly simple to find a hideout where
for large yetis can easily hide in the
city their terrible creature it's not
only that they can't even sketch the
scale I mean looking small that Yeti is
oh this pac-man gag is just clever
enough to make me realize how one clever
the rest of the movie is can I get a
current update on the status of these
streets because the ones that can easily
accommodate a snowmobile should not be
the same ones on which the cruisers can
easily navigate
[Music]
you know what they say but he who is
without any regard for human life in
this helicopter cast the first stone
what are those things if memory serves
the bad guys at the end of dire - just a
publicity stunt for ratings even if they
somehow thought that Percy Jackson here
was behind one of the creatures that
just completely rampage their town how
do they explain the other two creatures
which looked completely different that
hundreds of people saw not to mention
how much phone video evidence there
should be wow that guy was my fame yeah
but you have something better
integrity how does Brenda know this she
wasn't in the woods when Percy shot me
go up and it's not like he's had time to
explain everything to her the only thing
more idiotic than the fact that this
phone isn't lost broken or dead by now
is that he would delete these pictures
instead of backing them up somewhere for
safekeeping at least until he figured
out a better way to introduce yetis to
the world don't do drugs kids even if
they make it look like you'd have a
bitchin time on him just like me go here
I know that I said it wasn't a small
foot but that wasn't true and I'm sorry
that I lied to you and you should
totally believe me now even though I've
changed my story several times within
the last 48 hours nearly 30 straight
seconds of standing and looking at each
other his fire workshop had all of its
merchandise explode at the same time so
there's no way there to even be a
building here to clean up let alone a
sign not since kendall Jenner used a can
of Pepsi to unite us all has a police
force so completely and easily converted
to peace also you could just tell
everyone what the deal is to fully
contextualize the arrival of the Yeti
and allay any concerns right use your
words Percy use your words
I will name him George and I will hug
him and peppermint's NewsView as you
might have heard we recently announced
the inaugural year of sin week it's
coming up soon holy Sh
sin week is an E convention that you can
access at all levels of patreon it will
have five cinemasins videos that we for
members panels a live podcast and much
more and if you're signed up at the top
tier you're eligible to attend sin week
in-person hang out with Chris Jeremy and
the sentence gang in beautiful Nashville
Tennessee
you'll be digging up a top go you'll
even be treated to some great food if
you haven't already sign up today at
patreon.com slash cinemasins join the
club we look everybody we might see some
octopus language mankind that word
should have new meaning for all of us
today we will be united in our common
interest we're going to survive today we
celebrate our independence
[Music]
while I'm here hi I'm Mego welcome to
the Himalayas
[Music]